[Musique]
c'est vers les nombreuses annonces
gouvernementales qui fleurissent presque
chaque jour ou chaque semaine en tout
cas et qui occasionnent des nouvelles
dépenses de manière extrêmement
importante 12 milliards d'euros en
l'espace de deux mois c'est ça vient
s'ajouter à une dette de 3000 milliards
d'euros en france alors on voit bien que
évidemment pour les foyers qui sont dans
le besoin c'est important et c'est une
aide qui est précieuse j'ai pas dit le
contraire en revanche ce qui manque
c'est une anticipation n'y a pas de ya
pas de regard du gouvernement actuel sur
une politique du long terme sur une
anticipation sur des réformes
structurelles de l'état il a été
beaucoup question aussi de la politique
énergétique de la france durant les
dernières décennies tout ça ça ne se
nommera pas avec des débuts saupoudrage
de coup de pouce au dernier moment dans
les 6 dernies mois qui précède
l'élection présidentielle il faut des
réformes structurelles et là dessus le
gouvernement et ministre du top que j'ai
appelé le le ministre des déficits
publics ne m'a pas répondu
[Musique]